robert spencer iran's proxy army in
lebanon
hezbollah fired missiles this week into
israel for the first time in a very long
time
and they do nothing without explicit
instructions from their sponsor iran
what is iran thinking to turn hezbollah
loose on israel now
iran is thinking that israel is alone
and isolated
that biden's handlers are not going to
stand by israel
and so this is the time for them to
strike
and to advance as far as they possibly
can and so we're going to see
considerably more aggression against
israel than we have seen already
from hezbollah but also from hamas from
islamic jihad
from all of them and more because the
islamic republic of iran is emboldened
by biden's handler's weakness
and thus all the more aggressive